okay where did we finish yesterday I
think we just barely on my last threats
finished deriving the result first
Simpsons rule but we are we didn't
really have time to use it so that's
what we're gonna do this morning we'll
have a look at an example I'm just like
we're trapezoidal we'll see how it works
with basic form and then when you go a
bit longer okay so this is a very
typical question you give it an area for
an integral equivalent to an area
because intervals an area are so closely
related we've already established
they're not the same but they're very
very closely related you can therefore
think about this has a method of
approximating the integral without even
thinking about the area if you wanted to
okay so it can be quite separate and
later on probably not today we'll see
how we go when you would get volumes has
nothing to do the area right but it's a
cover to the integral so that's one
right so let's start off with Part A
then we're using Simpsons rule it says
two sub intervals okay now this is
really a good time to you know step back
again and think about language I'm going
to think about trapezoidal rule and
Simpsons rule and how they differ okay
now let's just rehearse
don't worry about when you've got
multiple forms multiple Lots on there
let's just think about the basic form of
each of these rules can you help me
remember what is an area approximately
equal to according to trapezoidal
understand H onto this is just one
little easier right so what am I gonna
have you do just one trapezium
this is one so this is a trapezium right
so it's the UM perpendicular height and
then it's got two parallel sides right
and I take the average of those already
taking the average of the top is about
and the two parallel sides are the
function values that you get yeah okay
good now what did we learn
yesterday the basic form of citizens
rule okay you again have each little
section right but it's H pon-3 which on
three okay but what do we have in the
brackets we're using a parabola to
approximate the curve okay
and it probably needs how many points to
be defined uniquely three points right
one two three so you've got the first in
the last just like before right and then
you've got the midpoint how many of the
midpoint do we have okay now you can see
they're quite similar and when you start
to build have extra ones right this
becomes one two two two two two one in
the middle right this becomes one four
two four two four two four one and they
alternate in the middle okay you've also
got the Doozers between the two and the
three how do you remember that I don't
know I know some people get taught that
for susur's rule
you remember that Homer Simpson has two
children if your mind is so inclined
that's fine okay um or what a
mathematical sort of way of memory is
look I've got two values here one two
cuz that's what repeating has so it's a
two and I've got one two three values
here so that's a three
whatever works now let's think about
these things some intervals function
values and so on okay if you have n sub
intervals
in suck it or watch it easier alright
how many function values are you going
to have just then plus one all right
function values okay because once you
PCM it's not two times two two pieces
you got one two three and so on okay now
how many here's a tricky word you'll see
it I'm going to mention it not because I
like it not because you'll see it in
exams but because you see in textbooks
how many times we're using the room or
every time you add a new sub interval or
a new trapezium right they call in the
application of the trapezoidal rule okay
now you'll see the second way this is
such a confusing word I would try and
avoid it but you've seen it sometimes
fits for example is a a really bad
culprit he's like every different kind
of word possible I think he's just
trying to you know tell you that there's
lotsa different options but it can be
very confusing so if you ever see the
word you know use use for applications
of trapezoidal rule okay what you're
going to get is for trip easier for some
intervals and five function days so this
is okay now let's compare that to sit
with parameters and stuff right if I
have M sub intervals okay so that's what
I've got here
you carefully
this is something cool for Simpsons rule
it's it's you know this is a subinterval
right now there's one and there's
another one so that's 2 subintervals and
that requires one two three function
values right so this is still the same
plus one function values but the
important thing to notice here is that
as opposed to trappers honorable I
mentioned this at the end of yesterday
right
you can pick however me subintervals
black right you can't just pick any
number of subintervals okay the Simpsons
rule you can't just pick any number of
function values you need to have an odd
number of function values to make sense
this rule work which kind of implies you
need to have an even number of
subintervals to make that work okay sir
no applications right that's how many
trapezium you have here applications of
me how many parabolas you have right now
if I have let's just take this example
right this is 2 subintervals 2 3
function values how many parabolas are
there how many applications having
turned about using the rule once 2
subintervals 3 function values one
application ok what if I wanted more
accuracy what would be the next step up
right I'm gonna have to write so Street
applications well what's that gonna mean
for the rest ok so now how many
something tools how many function does
is 5 so what's the relationship it's in
or two isn't it on two applications in
on two parameters which by the way this
tells you why this has to be even of
course has to be even because if you're
dividing by two how are you going to get
an actual proper number of problems at
the end unless this is 2 4 6 8 etc okay
right now we had that you know hits
actually start to answer this question 2
subintervals
so this is the basic form then for but I
just wrote down there okay
so I always start every single time just
by writing out the form okay it won't
get you any marks but it will tell you
all the things that you need to know in
order to answer the question okay so you
start off and there's an H there all
right so what's H equal to in this case
and this is where the drawing does help
you okay agency was the height of each
assignment tool now because it's a nice
easy value you don't really need too
much sophisticated work yeah you can
just tell me that the perpendicular
height is perpendicular height of each
subinterval Etheridge's is right that's
okay so all right now what what are all
these feathers here okay a and Spencer
and B right a is 1 and B is true so
therefore the average between them is
just so now let me translate all of that
the area out there for the integral
problem is approximately equal to this
on 3 is 6
okay and then what have I got here I've
got F of 1/4 and so do you see what I
did that start with the formula and then
I think okay what do I need to fill this
out I've worked out what those all are
separately and now I want you to hear
okay now a lot of people including you
guys
we stop doing all of these steps up here
okay and you're just go directly to this
step that mean the first line you guys
no problems with that
okay but I'm a math teacher and I still
write this first one number one - oh
yeah okay so you know now that I have it
in its sort of clean form which I've
memorized
okay I won't mix up these two okay but
secondly is just less error-prone right
if I have to memorize the formula and
then put all the values in and work them
out at the same time in an exam you're
asking for like you guys they're helpful
frustrating is to get back up a pop and
you're like I know how to do this stuff
it's just silly errors okay so this is
exam technique right you use a technique
which is let every you'll lose about 15
seconds to write all of that down what
the fifteen seconds right oh it's
actually evaluated now so now it's just
sort of mechanical stuff right my fault
my function is one of X okay so one on
one is that for lots of that's three on
two
so if I take the reciprocal it's true
all in three and that's gonna be tough
okay so get your calculator out I think
from memory that's what you someone tell
me